[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my name is Jillian Garrity and I'm the
creative director on Tom Clancy's the
division - on Black Friday a strain of
the smallpox virus was released on
dollar bills in New York City the
infection and chaos spread across the
nation seven months later the virus has
mostly burnt itself out but America is
tearing itself apart Washington DC is at
the heart of this battle under constant
threat from dangerous factions civilians
are trying to rebuild in their survival
lies the seed for the rebirth of society
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the rules and there will be
consequent will be made keep still
[Music]
[Music]
you at the last line of defense for
those civilians and for the country if
you fail history will be written by
tyrants
if you succeed history will remember the
few brave heroes who fought to save a
dying nation this setting lays the
groundwork for a compelling story based
campaign in which your actions have a
clear impact on the lives of civilians
in the division to Washington DC must
prepare for the greatest threat it has
ever encountered to face it
you and your fellow agents will need to
bring your equipment and tactical
abilities to the next level once the
agents reach the end of the main
campaign it's time to select a new
progression path by picking a
specialization it starts with the choice
of a signature weapon powerful and
unique weapons that compliment
the rest of your equipment as you
progress with your specializations you
will not only grow in power but also
unlock additional tools and abilities
including exclusive versions of skills
specializations enable you to truly
complete your own personal playstyle but
also to synergize with other players and
take teamplay even further speaking of
teamwork I'm excited to announce that
for the first time eight players will be
able to partner up to face the ultimate
and game challenge raids are coming to
the division
[Applause]
we learned a lot we learned a lot from
working on the first game and with the
division - we're launching with plans
for years of frequent major content
updates today we're ready to outline our
plans for year 1 we will be launching 3d
LCS in the form of episodes each one
will bring new story new areas to
explore and new activities and the best
part all of these episodes will be
completely free for every
[Applause]
where's my division team stay tuned
after the Ubisoft conference for an
exclusive 30-minute deep dive into a
playable III demo during our post show
as you can see they're getting ready
right now and they'll be playing right
after the conference is done until then
remember this is history's defining
moment hope for the future lies in you
agents of the division thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
keep coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]